Ugly. Depressing.
A cross between a giant square box
and a federal penitentiary.
These are all ways that
people have described
this building behind me.
It's Evans Hall at the University
of California, Berkeley.
It's built in a style of architecture
called brutalism.
And when you look at college campuses
around the US...
you'll see brutalist architecture
like this everywhere.
Why are there so many brutalist
buildings on campuses?
And what about this style of architecture
makes it so divisive?
Okay.
Just to start with,
the name Brutalism
doesn't actually have anything to do with
the brutality of the architecture per se.
Although some may argue that
it’s quite harsh in appearance.
It's actually derived from
a French phrase.
Béton brut.
The raw concrete
in French.
This is Timothy Rohan.
He's a professor of architectural history
at UMass Amherst.
A campus known for its stunning,
brutalist architecture.
It's also the home of UMass Brut...
a campus organization that raises awareness
of the school's collection of buildings.
Some architects...
in conversations about Brutalism
and its origins come up a lot.
One of them is the Swiss-born
French architect Le Corbusier.
He built an enormous building
in Marseilles, an apartment building.
The Unité d’Habitation.
This really became a model
for the use of concrete...
and a model for what became brutalism.
Concrete was widely used
but sometimes before this,
you would maybe
sand the surface,
paint the surface...
clean it up in a groundbreaking fashion.
He left the concrete surface raw.
Le Corbusier continued to build on the motifs
he used in Unité d’Habitation
in his later work.
Other architects of the day
played in the Brutalist sandbox as well...
such as Marcel Breuer,
Paul Rudolph...
Högna Sigurdardóttir
and Louis Kahn.
Brutalism became not just
a style of architecture...`
but an entire esthetic ethos.
In what became a manifesto of sorts
for the movement...
architecture, writer, and critic
Reyner Banham
decreed that new brutalist structures
should have the following qualities:
One: Memorability as an image.
Two: Clear exhibition of structure.
And three: Valuation of materials “as found.”
Modernist architecture up to this point
was dominated by people like
Ludwig Mies van der Rohe...
who built sleek glass corporate skyscrapers...
which featured what are called
curtain walls:
Non load-bearing veneers
that were meant to hide the construction.
Some architects say if you have
a whole city like this
it's going to become
banal, monotonous.
Modernist architects called
these buildings fish bowls.
And they were lampooned for their
resemblance to graph paper.
In contrast, brutalist buildings strove for
honesty in their materials
and structure.
They showed you how they were constructed.
At the end of World War II...
College attendance shot up.
There was the veterans returning
from the war
who were eligible for government benefits
that allowed them to go to college
and pay for it.
This necessitated that universities
build new facilities to handle
ballooning admissions.
And with so many new buildings
being needed...
what did architects of the day turn to?
Brutalism.
Sorry.
Schools like Yale had entire campuses
of brutalist architecture spring up
Which received glowing marquee reviews
in the New York Times.
Campuses across the country
erected some pretty spectacular buildings...
that typified the challenging and idealistic,
brutalist esthetic.
Schools like Harvard, UMass Dartmouth,
UC San Diego...
the University of Chicago, and
of course, Berkeley.
Some of the colleges like Yale University
they wanted to part from the old models
of the Gothic and the Georgian.
A campus that was like Oxford
or Cambridge for elite gentlemen.
Now they want to show that
they are becoming
a world class research university.
A university like mine,
University of Massachusetts...
expanded at this time from
an agricultural college...
and it becomes a research university.
A flagship campus of Massachusetts.
And so they start to become
the hosts for modern architecture...
to show their progress.
During the 1970s, the US economy
took a downturn.
New construction on campuses
ground to a virtual halt...
and maintenance of existing facilities
was neglected...
leaving many buildings
brutalist and otherwise...
dingy and in need of renovation.
And there's real cutbacks
in maintenance during the 70s.
It's noticeable.
And there's even a policy
that many campuses had
called deferred maintenance.
We're not going to do repairs.
We're not going to unstop the gutter.
We're not going to put in air conditioning
that was never installed.
It's deferred for a future date.
When will this day come?
I think it's maybe today.
The 1980s swept in a new era
of construction
that was a definite change of pace.
Architects like Robert Venturi designed
university buildings that featured
brighter colors...
asymmetrical shapes and
playful design elements.
Instead of attempts to preserve or renovate
brutalist buildings in need of repair
numerous campuses across the country
opted to tear them down and
build something shiny and new.
And that is what it seems like
will be the fate for poor Evans Hall
here in Berkeley.
Although a campus spokesperson told me
that there is, quote,
“No project in the works, or approved
to demolish Evans Hall...”
They went on to say that
they're in the process of relocating
all classrooms and offices
out of the building.
And will then construct new buildings
to house them, at which point
they will propose a project
to demolish Evans.
Which sounds to me like
they're going to tear it down.
The reason for all of this
is a study that showed
that its seismic rating
against earthquakes is poor.
So why is there no talk about
tearing down this building?
Or this one?
These buildings and over
22 others on campus...
share the same seismic rating as Evans.
So why set your sights on just Evans?
It's often about a number of other considerations,
like real estate.
The fact that these sites are
valuable space
on college campuses
is at a premium.
The real reason may be buried
further in the report
which says that, quote,
“Due to its massing height...
scale and materiality, Evans Hall
which obstructs views
to San Francisco and beyond...
is considered incongruous
with the Beaux Arts Buildings
in the Classical Core.”
And that, quote, “the ad-hoc placement”
of the new buildings “lacked sensitivity.”
My council is, be patient.
Just because you find something
unfashionable at the moment...
doesn't mean you should eradicate it.
But while Brutalism hasn't been seen
in a positive light for a few generations...
all hope is not necessarily lost.
There does seem to be a bit of
a renaissance happening.
Dr. Rohan hopes to spread
the gospel of Brutalism
to a new generation
by doing tours of the brutalist buildings
on the campus of his university.
And Zillow has even named Brutalism
as one of the top trends to watch
in 2024.
When you look around,
Brutalism influence
has actually made its way into many corners of our culture.
There are $1,000 concrete
West Elm coffee tables...
and Jay-Z and Beyoncé paid
$200 million
for a brutalist inspired house
on the ocean.
I think it has seeped into popular culture...
through Instagram,
through Pinterest.
All these things.
It is a very expressive architecture.
It photographs really well;
it's like cats on the Internet.
It just spreads.